I think part of the biggest problem is
just how the problem is framed okay and
that's what makes that's one of the
biggest things that makes probability
tells you like I said the number
crunching is just addition and
multiplication that's all the other 99%
of talking the question is
interpretation so let's really carefully
I'll be how many consecutive draws need
to be made so immediately you're asking
a fundamentally different question
you're not asking the question of what
is the probability bla bla bla which
will give you a fraction of some kind
okay you're asking how many right so
it's going to be an integer of some kind
yeah obviously probably it will be
involved but already we're trying to a
pretty primitive name how many
consecutive draws need to be made for
then it to be greater than 98 percent
chance that at least one jackpot prize
within one okay so there's the next
challenge right that he's the
probability of at least one jackpot
being one but I don't want a specific
number
I haven't any quality right at least
sorry greater than 98 percent greater
than 98 percent okay so we've got two
problems right the first problem is it's
almost a different question
Ty Lee the second problem is it's not an
equality at all it's an inequality how
do I even go about this let's consider
this guy probability of at least one
now how can I start to work with this
well there's lots of different ways just
like in this scenario there's lots of
different ways that this can happen okay
for instance I could have been on the
first draw that'd be nice right
what were the probability of winning on
the first draw 1 over 60 good but
clearly there are more ways to win than
that I might win next time
okay and he's the important thing number
one it's not simultaneous this is a
separate event now so I'm adding but for
the next time right what that implies is
I did win the first time right now I'm
gonna win on the second try right
so therefore hmm if I didn't win it here
then
I lost the first time and then I won the
second time right that's a way to get at
least one jackpot right turn okay
suppose I don't win the first time don't
win the second time I could win the
third time right times okay now what is
this thing what is this I mean obviously
it's goes on forever right but this
looks to me like it's a GP isn't it
right just to make it more obvious you
take out your common factor whatever is
60 right and then you're getting one
plus 59 over 60 plus 59 over 60 and so
on okay now it actually has to end
somewhere doesn't it because you're not
gonna sit there doing jackpots forever
the last one would be I guess if you
drew it n times if you had n draws what
would the last number be this is the
first draw this is the second drawer
second drawer that's a third drawer the
enth draw must be 59 over 60 M minus 1
now that's the thing you want to be
greater than 98% okay so you can fold
that into a GP you can take some and you
can sold for in from there but I don't
like that way of doing it
my brain hurts even looking at it right
and it's long it's very time-consuming
right is there a better way or maybe I
should say how do I get to a better way
than this okay well like I said I told
that language right see this see this
it's thinking if it deliberately we're
like is to obscure it and to make it
hard to work for it
this is a complement of something right
or I could say the complement of this is
something else there's much much easier
to work out okay what's the only way for
you not to win at least once and the
answer is you have to win zero
you just got to keep losing right so now
reverse the game okay if you reverse the
game you say okay what's the probability
of me never ever winning right okay so
probability of never winning how do you
work out this thing right instead of 1
over 60 right instead of 1 over 60 you
want to get 59 over 60 right and then
what do you do to this thing remember I
never win never ever ever ever ever okay
so for instance if I if I drew it let's
go back to this if I drew it four times
right
how many times do I have to do this to
never win and the answer is all four
times or four times if I did it 40 times
I need to do this for 40 times right if
I did it n times right n draws I'd have
to lose n times okay this this is much
easier to work with than this sort of
disaster in here okay now because this
is the opposite of this this is a
compliment right I don't want this to be
98 percent I want this to be cheaper sir
right or I almost wanted to be 2%
remember we said the beginning the first
problem is it's about how many the
second thing is that it's inequality
right so I should have an inequality in
here which way should it go I want the
probability of never winning which is
which is this I want it to be less than
two percent less than two does that make
sense I want this to be greater than 98%
that makes this less than 2% now to
solve this to work out which way like
what value I am going to go back to this
equation right when you solve that that
would give you the boundary point and
then you can decide which way to go
okay so when you look at this guy let's
make it a decimal
to work with it a little easier for 59
over 60 equals 0.05 in there okay so I'm
solving for n so how do i rewrite this
thing and I'll need to use a log we're
not okay so it'll be log base base what
the basis thing is saying the base here
becomes the base right so 59 over 60
okay I'm I want it to eventually get to
0.02 and n becomes the new subject right
we know this with logs
so now in order to evaluate this in the
calculator at least you'll need to do
change of base right so I'll say N
equals how should I do it I try to I try
to do sort of default to natural log
okay so you got that on the top and this
on bottom okay and you calculator will
make mincemeat of that right now you get
a decimal additives because all these
numbers are all the keys right I think
you get but 232 points someone got it
there 7-5 blah blah blah doesn't matter
okay
now you have a decision to make do I
have to go up or do I go down okay now
your tour tentative you can think about
it logically or under exam pressure
you're like my logic sort of centers
just fried okay you can just try it you
can just try it because there are only
two options from here right it's either
gonna be round down right all round up
okay now your intuition we tell you it's
one or the other but I'm just
considering you don't really need to him
you don't you don't want to risk it to
try it it's very easy to try okay here's
my end right in here right so what a
mile 10 is is 59 over 60 ^ 232 right I
can work that out that'd give me a
decimal or some climb what will it be
0.01
two three was it 2-0 to zero what to
zero to five okay now what did I want
I wanted the probability to be less than
2% but I am over two percent right I'm
over two percent I'm not there yet I'm
not
underneath that threshold I have it
limbo and live yet so I've got to go one
more if you do it if you multiply by 51
over 60 one more time you should just
think under right what do you get zero
point zero one nine nine hey guy we just
stuck underneath okay which means
obviously the complement of this will be
greater than I am today will be ninety
eight point zero one percent you get the
idea okay so you can see that even
though it's so simple like ah the
complement not heads not tails that's
basic stuff well can you identify it
right can you identify it that's what
it's all about and then it makes
problems just sort of fall out really
easily like if you can pick them out